it's a very maybe outdated system i
think there's a lot of problems with it
i mean it means a lot of really good
films probably don't get made and a lot
of films with the same silly actors
we've seen a million times over always
in the same movies because
how confident were you that you could
pitch this movie and sell it to
investors
so i think having this proof of concept
that i made was super helpful to both
give me the confidence because i knew
i'd made something really great with
that
um but then i just knew it was also
going to make it so much easier to sell
the movie to people um
but i knew no one you know i
have no friends or family connection to
the industry i have no agent or manager
i still don't even as of right now
like it's such an outside world
hollywood the true system right it's not
very welcoming to to outsiders you know
i mean
it's it's very tough to kind of break
those walls and so
um it just took a lot of time and being
super persistent i mean i just never
gave up and that's really how this movie
got made because there's plenty of times
where i thought
man this is never gonna happen i should
give up um but i didn't i just kept
going and that's really how this movie
got made no almost no other of course
their script was good the proof of
concept was good i got lots of luck
along the way but more than anything it
was just this persistence of not giving
up and continuing to fight for it and
just telling myself i was gonna make
this movie doesn't matter if i was like
a hundred years old by the time i got
made like i was gonna make this movie
one way or the other at some point and i
think that's just how how it got made
so no agent or manager and the film
opens in 10-ish days
in theaters and on-demand right yeah
yeah yeah you basically rent it wherever
you can rent things and then it'll be in
i think 10 different cities the first
weekend yeah playing
wow okay so when you hear people say
well i don't have an agent or manager
was that you at one time saying that or
was that never again resourcefulness you
don't worry about that i think after
having a little bit of a window into it
when i made this first feature when i
was in high school basically and then
spending a decade or so kind of adjacent
to the industry but not really in it by
doing a film festival and directing
commercials i think i just
i realized enough that
it's very difficult to do anything but
that this industry
it doesn't really want to
go and find people it really wants to
wait until you already have something
for them and they'll maybe find you and
so i kind of knew i never even tried to
get an agent or manager because i just
knew it was probably a waste because
i don't know i i guess i didn't think
until i had something
that i could really show as a success
that i would be able to be of use i
guess to them in that way and so maybe
that's just my own i guess thinking or
being too critical but i just think
that's there's no guarantee just because
i know plenty of people who've gotten
agents or managers and nothing happens
you know and so i think more than
anything it's just about what are you
going to create yourself and
i think that's the key to everything of
course that could open a lot more doors
and that would have probably sped up the
process if i had had that for sure
because it took still probably
four years from the time i'm starting to
write it to getting to finance it you
know which that's still a long time i'd
like to get that a lot shorter hopefully
for the next one
but
yeah i think above all you just need to
kind of
go go at it and and figure out a way and
and you'll eventually if you're if your
script and your thing is good enough i
think people will eventually take note
and it'll get get made it just might
take quite a long time
can you take us through the process of
how you got the money for borrego like
step by step sure
so
i think with anything with features
the financing is so much based on the
cast
and this kind of perceived value that
the cast has so
for better or worse you know that's how
a lot of movies get made i would say
that there's even movies that made where
the financing
folks or the distributor maybe doesn't
even read the script all the way you
know they look at what is this film
and who's in it you know um that's not
all the cases but you know so many ways
that's how films get made and so
that was really clear that we needed
some sort of talent um to kind of
finance this movie um now my film
consists of one
female lead who was written as
caucasian
then the rest of the cast is all latino
and this kind of sad reality of holly
hollywood is that
neither of those people have as much
value as maybe like a white man actor
and um
especially the latinos was hard because
there's a couple names
who we all know who are really famous
right but unless it's one of those names
everyone else
in hollywood's eye has basically no
foreign value or no kind of
you know i mean value in the sense of
what they think is value right um
and then
[Music]
there's also not as many um
probably um
female actresses who also have the same
value as like as a male actor and so
it was a tougher position to be and i
even had a few producers tell me like
hey you should change one of the
characters to like the sheriff in my
movie
who is also latino even though he's not
a drug dealer or anything like that but
it just it was authentic to this world
and this town we were in right i didn't
want all the bad guys just to be mexican
or whatever and so
but you know multiple times someone said
well change that guy into a white guy
and we can get someone who's more famous
to play that part and that will help you
finance the movie or even the lead
character maybe if that was a man i mean
it sounds cliche and kind of crazy but
that was still really what people were
saying you know and
it's um
you know
it took a lot of pushing back too
because i
i really wanted to make this film
authentically with especially the the
latino actors
i wanted them to be
totally authentic and so you know these
were
these were i spent a year plus looking
for for actors from central america and
mexico where
um
they were just amazing actors but maybe
were kind of under under undiscovered in
a lot of ways so like one of our actors
this was his first american film he'd
ever been in you know but his so his
value was basically zero we'll say in
terms of dollar and so what that meant
is we had to put all the value into our
leading actress and that eventually
ended up being lucy hale who got that
part um and so it was basically her
value financing the film and
she um you know for her this was a
really also a really kind of big
stepping stone film in terms of
um
performance in her kind of career too
because she had never done a film like
this you know she came from a very
famous tv show that was she was on for a
decade or so that became very famous
and she's done other features but she's
never done something quite this serious
in this kind of media she was really
excited about it um but she does have a
lot of value because she has a huge fan
base and her films that she has been in
have done pretty well and so we were
basically had to use her value because i
as a director had no value because this
was really my first real real film and
so
that's how they looked at it the we'll
sign by they i mean hollywood and the
financiers how they looked at how this
film should get made and so that
basically gave us a number that we could
then kind of create to what is the
budget of this movie you know it was
almost working backwards like this is
how much we'll pay you and this is what
the movie
can be made for kind of you know and
it's a
it's a very maybe outdated system i
think there's a lot of problems with it
i mean it means a lot of really good
films probably don't get made and a lot
of films with the same silly actors
we've seen a million times over are
always in the same movies because
um they get made or you see these really
kind of crappy action films with one
famous person and get made you know
because of that
so it's not a great model but
unfortunately
at least as at the time i made this
movie that's the model i had to fit into
to get this movie made
and so that's how i did it we had to
kind of work in that system but i was
lucky to be able to
by getting this one actress who had
enough value she then allowed me to then
cast the rest of the movie with people
who were not as
as famous and were more just really
talented compelling actors who authentic
and and could bring so much to the movie
so in the end it all worked out but it
was really hard and um just very
thankful that uh lucy got excited about
it and wanted to join it because she's
really what from that point on is really
what compelled to get this movie
financed
right and sorry this came from a casting
director that you were able to get her
the script yeah so you know i had i'd
said i was sending my proof of concept
short film and my feature around to
various people
one person who i met probably ten years
ago who was an assistant at the time was
now like an executive
and she was working in tv but she knew
some people in film and so she sent it
to this producer
uh he liked the both the script and the
short i had done
and so he wanted to try to help me get
it made you know so he had a casting
director that he was working with all
that often
where she
you know we had no money to start paying
anyone so she agreed to kind of help us
out on as a favor and just send the
script to a few of the agencies you know
and get their feedback and see you know
if there were some names that they had
that they thought might be
interested in this kind of project and
so that's how we kind of started the
process so we got
different names of some actors
and from there lucy's name was was in
that list and
you know at first
i mean i knew her name i knew she was
but i was i was not it wasn't like oh my
god that's her she's she's ellie because
you know she had been in pretty little
liars and there's other shows where it
was very much kind of teen drama kind of
type stuff and that's not what borrego
is
but
i watched some of her work and i
realized that she's this incredible
actress that just hadn't been really
given these high quality scripts and
and
projects to to seek her teeth into
because she is a really amazing actress
and i knew that this would almost be as
good as working with a
uh undiscovered person because no one
has would have seen her do this kind of
role so it instantly became super
exciting for me to have her because i
knew she would have the kind of the
famous clout or whatever to get us get
the movie made and market it but she
would almost be like introducing someone
to the world again because she had never
done something like this and that's what
it was i mean she's incredible in this
and i'm so excited for people to see it
because it she is amazing in it um
so yeah that's that's really kind of how
it how it worked for me
and the sheriff the decision to have him
as a single dad i thought that was
interesting
we don't really hear too much about
single dads that's kind of interesting
yeah i am
i don't know you know i don't know where
that personally came from that wasn't my
experience but i guess i liked this idea
of the dad and daughter relationship
um i kind of liked i wanted all the
characters to have something they were
struggling with you know and so
him he's this
sheriff deputy sheriff in a very small
little town where there's not very much
action you know he hands out speeding
tickets that's kind of his his job right
and we don't really talk about it in the
film but the idea is that he's probably
also kind of run away from something or
has come here to have kind of a safe
place for him and his daughter
and he's not looking for any trouble and
doesn't see much action and so he's kind
of thrust into this action and is
totally out of his comfort zone his
daughter then ends up getting caught up
in two and so his worst fears have all
come you know together with that and so
i think i just like the idea that he had
so much on the line with just being
fully responsible his whole life was
really being taken care of her and that
was was what he was fighting for in it
so that's kind of where his kind of
backstory came from yeah